[Music]
for dessert is an incredible but easy
hazelnut meringue tower guaranteed to
wow your mates start with a basic
meringue separate four egg whites
and whisk
[Music]
gradually add castor sugar
until the mix forms stiff glossy Peaks
gently folding ground and chopped
hazelnuts a trick we use in the
restaurants is to use the mix to stick
baking sheets down which makes them easy
to spread and stops the sheets blowing
around topping meringues with more
finely chopped hazelnuts and bake for 25
minutes and the trick to stop them
cracking is to turn the oven off and let
them cool inside for the filling melt
dark chocolate in a bowl over simmering
water and slightly cool whip the cream
until it forms soft peaks and gently
folding 3/4 of the melted chocolate
until combined
build your tower with alternate layers
of chocolate cream and meringue finally
drizzle over the remaining melted
chocolate to decorate a simple yet
luxurious dessert your friends will love
but be warned that all wants second
helpings